peace
[Music]
good rancher
the snowman dreams about summer days can
you find the things he would like to try
can you point to it with your beaks
randy
bad rancher
the throw i do for you
after all daddy rachel does for you
just what you can give me
[Music]
go with the good ranchers 100 american
source steakhouse quality means
subscribe today at
goodranchers.com crowder and lock in
your 25 off every box for the entire
life of your subscription
good ranchers american meat
delivered
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
i started smoking
that's why hearing that instead of a sip
look i just it's been a very stressful
uh it's been a very stressful year and
uh well look i i haven't introduced him
yet but i blame dave
sorry i uh i thought it would be a funny
prank and uh apparently uh
sneaking nicotine into your coffee every
day
no and it's also a horrible delivery
mechanism because if you consume
nicotine in liquid form orally uh i just
get sick i noticed that a lot of
vomiting yeah but it's good now though
you've only had what so was that your
ninth today well and they you know
that's a problem because they stopped uh
i had to start smoking palm oils they
stopped selling chesterfields i know you
palmoles just don't have the nice smooth
pull of a chesterfield recommended by
four out of five doctors oh easy and if
you know anything about me it's that i'm
a chesterfield man yep if a woman's
pregnant they assure you lucky strike
nine out of ten is the way to go yep
hold up dave you're out of focus dave is
out of focus all right look glad to be
with you today we have a lot to get to
uh baby formula shortage is a big deal
also i want to talk about the cdc no
one's talking about this the new crime
stats that were released and the cdc
presented it
with the preface that it's
because of systemic racism because of
systemic oppression that's why you're
going to see the statistics that you see
spoiler it's not it doesn't add up the
baby formula shortage okay look um
what's your my question to you is what's
your best suggestion for an alternative
first person who answers tits gets
banned
[Music]
though correct
uh
i'm open to all suggestions here's all i
had yeah i'm open to all citizens here's
the thing this is you know look what
elects democrats today is white suburban
middle class upper middle class women
this is an opportunity this hits them it
starts with hey i can't get baby formula
why
it's a really valuable opportunity right
now a lot of and this is because and i
know not everyone i know if you're
watching you watching right now the
woman watching this the lady watching
this you're engaged but you also have to
understand that you're an anomaly
typically statistically women
white suburban women are not engaged in
politics and vote because they're they
tend to be more agreeable they want to
do the nice thing and so they believe
that the democratic party is more
empathetic so only when it comes to
their doorstep to your doorstep
does it require thinking about these
issues that's what's happening with the
baby formula issue right now
and i can't tell you how many women i've
spoken with who
say i can't get baby from i said well
you know i have twins so we run these
circles and i said well why do you think
that is like i don't know well guess
what let's make sure they know you saw
the the segment yesterday where was just
you know talking with people which is
going to be a new segment you can
comment below uh that versus change my
mind what you like we we still plan on
doing both
it just is predicated on the idea of if
you talk with people and let them assert
just let them explain their position
you'll realize they often don't have one
and they go
what do you what do you think about it
what do you think it should be and then
you can suggest information rather than
arguing your point like you're on a
cable news show we have that opportunity
all of you right now with the baby
formula shortage sure a few babies are
gonna have to starve for us to get there
but you know what
there's look them's the brakes
take it up with the fda not me okay we
talking about that uh and of course in
studio because he is with child not here
gerald b
is still with us i've had just about
enough of your lip oh jeez
[Applause]
there's a supply chain issue with a
polytherin i was hoping that hole would
get bigger yeah well you know i wasn't
getting it was getting a little lippy
enough lip how you doing there gerald
i'm well how are you how's the little
one little one's doing fantastic he was
nine pounds nine ounces oh good lord
giant baby so maybe the maybe the
shortage will do him some good well no
he's he's on the boob thank god and uh
is he on uh plenty of supplies he should
be on baby watchers yes
tell them miss as i look forward to her
walking again yeah that is quite he's
doing uh fantastic 22 and a half inches
long wow good lord he's bigger than luke
at birth and by the way gerald's baby
bigger than me now his first baby was
the biggest baby i've ever seen in my
life i remember when i
saw him i think he was maybe nine months
at that point yeah how old is he in nine
months i said come on how old is no
really
looks like he was two he's very
yeah large human being he sent me a
video of dancing to ghetto cowboy and i
was like i didn't know you had a
teenager
especially when he said i hate you dad
i'm like yes that's not a one and a half
year old it started early all right now
that's so awesome thank you i appreciate
it you've heard him uh you love him and
we are we're in tulsa this week and
that's sold out but we do have shows in
uh together in uh oh yeah colorado
springs june 18th there still are some
tickets available for the early show
uh on twit not a lot at uh landau dave
dave how are you good ahoy how about you
sir i'm doing uh i'm doing i'm doing all
right you know like oh my gosh look at
the
second you know that still lives oh geez
now it's ash they're supposed to go out
so they don't kill you in bed but
apparently chesterfield still have that
old recipe let me see is it still lit
oh yeah oh yeah i hate the smell of
smoke oh i love cigarettes it you don't
like to smoke cigarettes no it reminds
me of my childhood me too yeah yeah oh i
had a great childhood i'm just
a cigarette canadian childhood we were
in a three-bedroom apartment with 25
chain smokers ah yeah that's well yeah
all i smell is smoke really exactly 15
20 years of my life well then i smoked
until i was
20 i suppose i was 30. 29.
one day from 30. well i would go to
grandma's house for thanks for uh for
easter dinner and come back with the
black lung that's very nice
and by the way hey guys look we don't
know what's going to be happening here
youtube is now making some changes that
we can't fully but uh if we don't let
you know that we're not doing a show you
can always go over to rumble right
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
of course on mug club we do an extra
full 45 minutes sometimes an hour of
show today is chat thursday yeah which
is always a lot of fun where we take as
many chats as we possibly can as opposed
to you know playing a gamer segment so
all right
let's uh get to the news shall we you've
been keeping abreast something happening
yeah yeah yeah
uh i mean i've just been thinking about
babies the whole time and you don't have
to worry about the shortage at all
because no
don't take his work well but i i also
chest fed him did his work and it works
get to work so i'm just saying man work
work
i'm sorry gerald's wife for watching
this is not i don't mean it in any type
of uh uh obviously not disparaging uh
and i don't know what i would say you
know uh
wonderful breasts but i just you know
what let's go to the setup
again i don't wanna
uh so
what else do i have to throw you know
what we should do for the next build bar
commercial is just place them gently no
between the no wife i'm just saying that
uh totally something i agree with yes
let me get the knife out again
oh yeah that is true you need to give
him a giant blade yeah yeah and then
started talking trash very impractical
weapon by the way a kitchen knife like
that well there's no hand guard okay
that's true you know who wishes that
they had uh they had a knife like that
is uh apparently best buy um they only
hire the cream of the crop when it comes
to their employees here's some stuff
that has been going down recently
security camera footage ah yeah okay
watch here you go
nice average shoppers yeah well oh free
hmm
well at least they're casual about it
yeah that one guy can't he can't get the
one out
any
attention oh and there's
blocking oh yeah there's the security
guard
that's just someone who's had enough
yeah
he's i didn't see that before i saw the
part where they were like shuffling back
and forth but not the take down that's
the first time i've ever seen a best buy
employee every time i'm there i'm like
hey could uh no no help with anything
i'm gonna go i'll just go online then
thank you we'll only help with the 15
restocking fee yeah then they're happy
the return policy again with a 15
restocking it's wonderful
yeah well we have to pay it we have to
restock it you mean you have to take it
from me and put it there and that's 15
i don't think you deserve 15 an hour i
think you should live under a bridge
yeah now if you're that guy though who's
tackling them on the way out yeah 25 an
hour easy by the way that first one you
could tell uh can we watch that again
play that again this is one of this is
unfortunately the reality of uh the
racism bred
by the rhetoric here in our country so
of course you see okay the top left
criminal more everybody is one of them
is successful one of them is
more ethnic and then look at the look at
the one security guard look at the one
security guard that employee right there
that's a little white guy he's rolling
up his pants
but you see that one guy he's just he's
a he's
white this could be the bay area i have
no idea he's rolling up his pants he's
like all right okay
yeah call me racist all you want here we
go he's like an nba guy he's like
yeah i could have gone pro this is my
moment to get back yes exactly well you
know it's like in detroit this is what
happens is when you keep re breeding the
racial division and telling people they
can steal you have people who are not
racist whether they're white whether
they're asian and they say
all right that's enough you get rooftop
koreans you get the detroit violence
where there was the rebound effect after
the riots where then it became it wasn't
entirely a race war before that that's
actually what sparked what ended up
being more of the racial tensions in
detroit it wasn't it wasn't the
culmination to the race riots in detroit
that made it worse than ever before and
when you allow people to commit crimes
and you go and i'm not saying that all
black people are committing crimes let's
be very clear what i'm saying is that
the leftist party the democratic party
decides to go out and say well these
people need to be able to let's be
empathetic to it i'll read you the cdc
stats later where they say well crime
has gone up specifically only one
demographic but it's clearly due to
racism when you do that the people who
are the victims of crimes decide that
they've had enough
and you run the risk of when you label
the criminals exclusively by race but
saying but it's their race but it's not
their fault because of the race it's
your fault because of their race guess
what people say i guess this is a race
thing
also the restocking fee
yes and also well usually when you walk
out casually you can get away with it or
if an alarm goes off ever like cvs
they're just like hey i'm like i'm white
and they're like that's fine yeah they
honestly they don't care when i get
pulled over by a police officer i have
tinted windows highly illegal and i just
roll it down and go
and they're like
oh safari sir oh jeez be on your way
and they give you your choice of cupcake
or cookie yeah then they see the hodge
twin in the passenger seat like we're
going downtown
i didn't know you had your drug dealer
with you yeah
i didn't know you had a what is that
blue eyes is that a vampire from blade
yeah that's odd
the only time i got caught really
shoplifting was i was stealing a bong
that was three feet long and i just
casually put it into a springtime
jacket i'm sure wherever the locale from
which you were stealing the bong they
they probably weren't on top of it to
realize no no the security guard did
though and i walked out and there was a
giant maul and they were like uh excuse
me you have a graphics bong with a clown
on it hanging out of your coat and i was
like what that was drunk
how do you know it's a bunk because he
just left spencer's yeah yeah
also i can see the plasma ball in your
shorts
did you have to bring a lava lamp with
you and the poopy poster and the carmen
electroposition just gonna say yeah
cindy crawford drinking a pepsi
all available to miners thank you
spencer's right next to the yankee
candle store
the yeah of christmas right next to
total degeneracy right it really is you
guys go over there and play in that
store i can go pick up a nice douglas
fir scented candle and then a
double-sided dildo next door thank you
douglas for handcuffs yes exactly
uh spencer's still around i haven't been
to a shopping mall in years i hope not
they they are oh sadly yeah they are oh
man all right i don't know who spencer
is but i don't like him you know who
else i don't like and i had no idea he
was this crazy
james cromwell uh you probably know him
from step brothers and he's one of those
guys who appears in movies and you go
he's that guy from that thing yeah
and uh
he along with some other protesters
glued themselves to a new york starbucks
counter over and here's the thing it's
an animal rights thing
but
see if you can spot
the privilege
when will you stop charging us more for
vegan milk when will you stop breaking
in huge profits it's not about the
animal rights animals it's about the
premium
when will you stop penalizing people for
their ethnicity he's gonna read it
a
if you're reading it what's your belief
in that
the senseless upcharge hurts animals
like there's a rooster going 45 cents no
no what ah
for vegan thanks blind
let's go brandon
if your biggest problem in the world
right now is the extra money for vegan
milk you have the best life and you're a
billionaire yeah
i would imagine that it's also more
labor intensive i have not tried to milk
an oat no but
or a plant of some sort i i don't know
where'd you get the steel cut what's
wrong with you roger you know we gotta
get the old-fashioned rolled son of a
[ __ ]
i think it's just milk and they put
lactate in it and blend it and they're
like yeah it's from an almond there's no
way there's how do you milk an almond no
it's probably like uh what is that uh
it's new jack city it's just except they
just have a bunch of oats going by a
bunch of naked ladies just all right
there you go
stupid vegan milk just call it what it
is
crap so apparently starbucks i guess
they charge an extra 70 cents for the
dairy alternative is what they charge
and okay uh what's going on here no
more steven what are you talking about
do you ever heard trial
you're treating her so unfairly on your
show
i hate it
this is this is a protest over amber
heard okay
you need you need to uh compartmentalize
and keep your personal life out of your
work yeah we already let you off easy
for all the turds in the studio and i
don't know i don't know why you're doing
this yeah well little known fact james
cromwell is a personal hero of mine
and i saw how well the starbucks thing
went well it didn't actually go that was
this i don't think it went well
you used a glue stick
oh my goodness get out of here oh oh my
oh my heavens oh no holy cow oh no
he rolled well
okay
his bones sticking out yeah i know
that's what we call a compound
so uh you know about senator manchin
love him no cigarettes make sense
i saw mean streets who flicks a
cigarette oh it's the it's the greatest
insult that's the one thing
have you never flicked a cigarette at
somebody oh my gosh it's never so good
oh i have so many times there are so few
they're just it's the simple joys in
life like yeah a good flick of a
cigarette at a hobo yeah or in a
convertible oh yeah i've done that many
times yeah around like rags in a
department store not recently no not at
rags at a department store oh did i go
i'll do it on the cds at best buy like
who is a cd player
i mean it's my friend's car with them in
it but i flick it in the back and i
watch them panic they had it coming yeah
so uh senator manchin
he just uh joined republicans you may
know about this to stop the women's
health protection act now let me just
preface this with i know you're hearing
women's health protection act that
sounds nice
it's not
it has nothing to do with women's health
let me let mench and by the way i don't
agree with senator manchin on a whole
lot right but it's funny that he's
personal grotto the democratic party
because i will say even among all
politicians just from the standpoint of
not appearing like a crazy satanist he
speaks normally i find him actually very
agreeable
as far as his personality goes here he
is explaining why he refused to support
the women's health protection act and
the explanation matters the bill we have
today to vote on the women's health
protection act and i respect people who
support but don't make no mistake it is
not roe v wade codification it's an
expansion it wipes 500
500 state laws off the books
it expands abortion
and with that
that's not where we are today we should
not be dividing this country further
than we're already divided and it's it's
really the the politics
of congress that's dividing the country
it's not the people they they're telling
us what they want
and uh it's just disappointing that
we're going to be voting on a piece of
legislation which i will not vote for
today it's almost like he's too normal
so i don't trust him because he's a
politician what's the play what's his
angle yeah what's his angle no what you
want us to think you're normal
um
yeah he does and his name is from west
virginia right yeah i don't know oh
maybe that yeah he could have something
wrong going on southern charm though
goes a long way so before you bring up
the picture that uh i referenced the
first thing let me just reference the
bill here so you know the women's health
protection act you've heard me talk
about
how the left and if you watched
yesterday's uh installment on the street
actual leftists about 50 of the
democratic party they believe in
abortion all the way up until including
birth on demand period and if they would
have their way would be it would be
subsidized you know just like your uh
basket weaving degree wow so the bill
would have and i'm reading a quote here
among other things uh
it would have uh banned a prohibition so
it would have banned a prohibition so it
would have banned a ban
basically
it would have disallowed a prohibition
on abortion after fetal viability when
in the good faith medical judgment of
the treating healthcare provider
continuation of the pregnancy would pose
a risk to the pregnant patient's life or
health so really quickly uh bring up
that means that this women's protection
act would allow abortions of babies like
that
just to be clear
oh it's in the womb okay but that's
what's in the womb you have to look at
it yeah that's why they oppose the
ultrasound uh legislation where you just
have to have an ultrasound because
you're killing that this bill would make
it illegal
for
states to ban
killing that yeah two weeks ago today we
were within 12 to 24 hours of having our
kid yep we could have we could have
pulled the plug then you could have
pulled the plug right there on a nine
pound probably eight nine ounces already
right there at that well your baby at
like six months was eight months yeah
but i'm just saying like i would have
brought it to a pet cemetery to get you
back
[Applause]
as opposed to the one where the car
comes back because stephen king is just
kind of one more talented author yeah
i guess that's true sometimes they come
back sometimes something shawshank
redemption green mile i don't know it's
not like they all bleed together oh a
lot of stuff comes back
shawshank all right i think green mile
best one my favorite and also let's be
clear the patient's life or health
that's also health can also include
mental health what can mental illness
could be stress yeah
and a seven eight months baby might
stress her out
it stresses every pregnant mother out
yeah
i've never you ever met
a seven or eight month pregnant woman
who seems chill
[Laughter]
it's kind of when things are going hot
and heavy so you have to say yes really
yeah was your missus was she was relaxed
all the way up until i have to be honest
yeah 100 you were very fortunate very
very important yeah honestly and uh yeah
i can honestly say oh it was great don't
get me wrong i'm just saying there's a
lot going on she was stressed a lot
going on yeah yeah she was stressed well
no when you have the baby there's stress
and it's like that's part of it though
that sacrifice to bring another life
into the world yeah and then you
sacrifice the the life if you're a
democrat yeah so you know like yeah yeah
you can either sacrifice sleep or the
baby where else do you get child
sacrifices from dave yeah that's a good
point
that's the problem is they're taking
their they're taking their code book
from the mayans now senator elizabeth
warren
was uh upset that the constitution of
course is standing the way of of killing
seven and eight month babies and let's
be clear
i am using that term because it's what
it is
we're no longer at the point of arguing
viability that's a non-issue we're no
longer at the point of arguing rape or
incest that's a non-issue the democrats
wanted to ban
if they would have their way at a
federal level they would ban any
limitations for any reason on abortion
all the way up until nine months period
that's the party platform well you gotta
say democrat that's the party platform
yeah just to be clear so if you don't
believe
people say oh i'm a you know you don't
wanna be a single issue voter if you
don't believe that seven eight
nine month babies should be aborted or
at least if you don't believe that no
state should be able to place a
restriction on the killing of a seven
eight-month baby you are precluded from
ever pulling the lever
for someone with a d next to their name
it's not the only issue
but it is a closed-handed issue so
elizabeth warren is so upset about the
constitution standing in the uh in the
way of of killing these seven and eight
month babies that uh she decided to do
what elizabeth warren does uh which
means you know
ramble tackle i believe in democracy
and i don't believe that the minority
should have the ability 5149.
that the majority
that's not the constitution
does she need to grab a dictionary maybe
maybe maybe a thesaurus i like that
she's always wearing the exact same
thing yeah
she wears it well yeah she's just really
jobs of congress yeah she really is
she's she's like a robocop where if you
take she actually has no shoulders
in the suit
she's earthworm jim she's really just a
head
a head and a tube
with of course uh feathers from her
from her non-native american of course
at some point murphy had a soul yeah
yeah
just
she doesn't understand majority minority
51 also by the way the the constitution
is about uh
the majority not the the minority not
having their rights infringed upon by
the majority she does she just doesn't
none of what she discusses is correct
she doesn't understand that we are a
constitutional republic we are a
representative of republic and she also
don't understand what a basic majority
minority is is this the common core math
i think so because it may be why did it
predate our segment by uh like nine
decades
i think she's like well look i get that
the majority of people elected to vote
on this voted this way but if you take a
poll of people they you know especially
if you focus on california new york they
say yeah that's totally fine that's
pardon my language if you have kids i
just need to just i'm you know and also
the cigarettes are getting to me
it's complete horseshit when they try
and say the majority of americans know
when you ask the majority of americans
what do you think about roe v wade i
think it's a 60-something percent where
they say oh we don't think it should be
overturned then the vast majority of
americans believe that abortion should
be impermissible after the first
trimester and guess what if you actually
discuss with americans what happens
within that first trimester like a
heartbeat like development like fingers
and toes guess what their opinion
changes even more it doesn't take a lot
to educate people on this issue you saw
it yesterday where i was standing on the
corner with four black people
four african-american whatever term you
want people of color i'm just going to
go with black
and they said yeah yeah we're
we're pro-choice this is a woman's right
to choose i said was there like a
limitation he said yeah cause like at a
certain point i don't know it becomes
like murder i said so would you say like
a heartbeat and they said yeah yeah
definitely not after a heartbeat that's
messed up there you go that's all it
took done that's all it takes
just a little bit of education and
talking with people but if you're afraid
to do it because you're afraid to offend
your friends guess what you're not being
a good friend you know who's a good
friend of the show
good ranchers
[Laughter]
that's right
good ranchers and uh they're they're
they're kosher i don't know
don't mess that one up they're
absolutely not so
good ranchers is uh you get your your
meat delivered and here's what's really
i've this is a ribeye and it is
absolutely delicious it's all usda uh
choice or higher and it's american meat
they have chicken too they have pork
it's all american meat a lot of the meat
that you're getting at the store doesn't
come from the united states so they work
with small local ranchers so that they
can deliver the food to you they cut out
the middleman so you get a good price
it's better than stuff that you get in
the grocery store uh and the prices are
comparable and uh you need to try their
what is it they have the new uh the
waiguu burger those wagyu burgers are
great yeah the american they're
individually wrapped so they're easy to
cook you can also just use them like in
tacos and stuff but i just i just eat it
like a salisbury steak so for a limited
offer you get two pounds of free
american white goo wow and you get free
shipping when you use the promo code
crowder at goodranchers.com crowder i
think you get like a 25 off every
delivery for the lifetime of the thing
yeah and then the american wagyu is good
for the month of may oh for the month of
may
all right well it lasts longer than the
month of may because it's frozen yeah
well meaning the purchase oh jeez yeah
can i i would
can you have the yeah you can have the
robot okay no no no no i'll get after
the show
ribeye is so underrated it is uh yeah
when i go to a store i don't get the
when i go to a steakhouse i don't get
the flag at the room yeah i get the
robot it's so good
yeah people just yeah they think it's
filet there is a place though here i
don't know if i can say the name but
they're very affected the places that we
like but there's that one place that's
very effective it has a poster of
anthony bourdain giving the finger you
know what i'm talking about yeah yeah
i do you have one of the things right so
um
and they were charging like two hundred
dollars a steak
wow
and i said what what are you 200 for
this stick they go well and it wasn't
even like wai gu or kobe and
you know that well that was just to
order the whole left side of the map oh
right
steakhouse
yeah they call it the guy fieri special
i ordered
they call it the stelter yes
no so this place say 200
and they say i said this is ridiculous
it's a little expensive
you seem like you're a little affected
they go well sir
have you ever had a properly aged let me
stop you right there yeah i don't want
to have to kick your ass
but it will like every other steakhouse
got it wrong and they somehow got it
right and the steak actually wasn't even
that good it was actually probably one
of the worst rib eyes i've ever had like
we properly age it and because we
properly age it there is no seasoning
whatsoever tenderizing and it sits in a
locker i get it i understand the process
you're overcharging because you're a
prick now yeah the locker is at a planet
fitness yes
we let fungus grow on it yeah we cut it
off we let it grow in a locker of foot
yes
it's no good not good at all yes with a
nice uh jock strap glaze yeah more of a
reduction really ever seen seinfeld
where he poisons the whole troop yeah
that's it's pretty much like yes yes yes
i assure you at the end of the meal you
will be disappointed yes
two hundred dollars please yes and uh we
discourage you from leaving yelp reviews
yes please we turn them off we have a
geofence
we pay them handsomely to not allow them
to yes
[Laughter]
um let's talk about this the formula
shortage okay yeah this is something
that a lot of you know about and this is
something that affects families across
the country myself included and is a
real opportunity like we just talked
about the abortion issue to discuss this
particularly with with mothers of new
children
it just starts with the question
why invariably someone's bitching about
it right i can't believe this food
shortage i can't believe this formula
shortage why do you think that is
and there
to be fair
there there are quite a few reasons as
to why uh but the overall uh
reason is of course uh in inept
government and red tape and and there's
a problem that can a problem can be
created by a business or business and
then the government can make it worse
well and it's never been
extremely cost effective or abundant
ever really right yeah you know baby
formula yeah well it's tough to compete
with
america's favorite uh glass the bitty
land yeah that's what i meant free the
boobs
free the boobs so american shortage uh
uh may be the worst yet and
it's uh it has mothers are struggling to
feed their children
no i know
taylor miller can't allow even a drop of
formula to go to waste so you're
rationing for me rationing for me yeah
never did i think i would ever
be rational
the katy texas mom now feeds daughter
magnolia two ounces every two hours
instead of four ounces every four
in hopes of avoiding leftovers she might
have to throw out because it's spoiled
we'll literally waste a whole tank of
gas in a day trying to find formula and
maybe only find one can hey why is gas
expensive
this happened yesterday in that segment
where the one guy said you know it's
going to be really expensive to go and
get abortions out of state because gas
is crazy expensive and i said really
yeah it's pretty bad and then his
girlfriend said it's not that bad i said
you're trying to couch it because you
know you can't accept responsibility for
it yeah you know what there's a shortage
that's terrible hey why is gas expensive
hey why would the ingredients that you
might need to create your own formula
why are those expensive why is there a
shortage there it can't all be coveted
it just begs these questions and of
course the media can't do that just like
the media can't go out for an hour and a
half and talk with people on the street
because that's not what they do so
what kind of sociopath goes to get an
abortion and is like yeah and 63 dollars
in gas
what is wrong what is wrong with you it
cost me so much money to kill this thing
out loud
stop for mcdonald's that's a whole
nother bill
stop it's not all about you
[Laughter]
mindset do you have to have i can't
imagine an evil one and then the states
that are advertising like what an
abortion come to california where we can
still kill your child like what are you
doing well
you know any self-awareness at all yeah
they do have self-awareness they realize
that that's the only thing they have
left oh they have hollywood and
abortions
so nationwide same thing yes exactly
43 of the popular brands of formula are
out of stock wow uh
and in uh january through july 2021 the
rate was between two and eight percent
between november 21 and april 22 the
rate rose from 11 to 31 so six states
half of all baby formula was sold out
during the last week of april you have
texas tennessee missouri south dakota
north dakota iowa
and uh yesterday actually
our one of our producers here went to so
i've been looking online and uh stopping
by stores but our producer and he
happened to film it which really i
should have been thinking about that uh
he went to six stores looking for
formula he went to target he went to
kroger he went to tomtom he went to
walmart he went to cvs he went to bye
bye baby i don't even know they sold
formula baby they did i just thought
they sold very overpriced strollers and
bassinets also that they sell formula uh
there you go they also sell lead paint
chips to make the formula go further
it's like a thickener to help you get
rid of the one you don't want so this is
our producer going to the stores and you
can see because this is one thing too
when people show barren shelves right
early on the media so that's not really
true that's not a biden thing that was
uh from an old video this was taken
yesterday
or the day before yesterday
was it yeah i think it was yesterday
exactly yeah you can see the shelves
they were extremely low on supply here's
what it looked like at six stores
ridiculous prices
yeah i know this one is
fairly decent i don't know if you're
this was quite pretty good there's
nutrimage in there that's what i use
wow he could have picked that up for me
what a dick
oh
geez glassed off like a diamond necklace
that's what i use i haven't been able to
find her anywhere i went to like nine
stores lane get in here ginger snap
is he is he does he have to come in he
has to come in yes he absolutely has to
come in did you say i use the same thing
for my son for crying out loud get in
the chair lane get in the chair you saw
that there you know that's what we use
what's
you did you see in the video play the
video again just for the first so he has
to watch you watch you watch what
happened what am i looking ridiculous
prices hold on a second then we go
right past their new dimension there you
go lift it up tim that's enough that's
it
right there just what's what's wrong
with you with the cigarettes again it's
my thing now i think i want to make it
my thing are we smoking now no i just
want to flick the cigarettes man
so tell me what what happened you said
one employee even told you actually yeah
so actually at target the first tour i
ran into two people the first lady said
she was searching for formula for her
friend in iowa jill biden was there
the first lady
sorry secondly
she said she was looking for a friend in
iowa and then i met this man who's
shopping for his baby he said he'd been
to five stores couldn't find any and
most of the formula he'd been getting
recently he was ordering from europe
right which is technically illegal we'll
get to later it is illegal yeah
not technically like literally it's
literally illegal
right but it's so it's like but here's
the thing parents have been doing this
for years i think we have an overlay
from the new even the new york times
acknowledging that they've been getting
it from europe right so it's like i said
it's illegal it's actually illegal but
apparently it's not enforced
yeah it shouldn't be and what you said
that you said an employee to it bye-bye
baby
what did this employee tell you so she
said the first thing she said i asked
her if this shortage i buy babies a
convenient name if they keep running
them
i had to starve you so okay so i asked
her if the short like the shelves were
like this all the time she said well the
ever since coven started that it was a
little bit down but over the last couple
months it's been crazy and that
yesterday is as bare as she'd ever seen
them
and she said whenever they would get a
shipment in it would be gone within 20
minutes gosh and she's getting calls
every hour for parents asking parents
are panic panic buying right now yeah is
there anything else you need to let me
know well yeah so a lot of the stores
are like gerald alluded to they're
setting limits on how much people can
buy now it's like toilet paper or gas
people start going oh crap i need some
even if you don't need some right at
that moment and like at cvs they had
these things so basically coupons yeah
that's like jingle all the way a turbo
man yeah you get him it's turbo man
where's the turbo man are you thinking
under the impression there's a
troublemaker here in the studio we said
someone would get one eventually what i
have here is a gift certificate
except the beatings are still funnier
than sinbad yes they are it's a great
movie underrated
actually
for a holiday movie with the kids i
agree it's not that's fun but at cvs
they had when you went to the formula
section
they had these things that said oh
available at the front checkout so i'm
thinking okay they'll just have them
locked up or something yeah you go back
there and you're like okay can i get
some of these like oh no we don't
actually have any of those oh well
that's how you get those best buy
robbers i mean i can't blame them like
if you if i mean i'm just saying if you
ransacked the front i wouldn't blame you
but i'm gonna dock your pay for the the
uh formula you didn't pick up wow that's
awesome so i wanna want you to be here
because there's been a little bit uh we
had a little bit of a debate during
uh run through here and i i really would
love to see you guys commenting below by
the way the best thing you can do is do
we have a share button
yeah
apparently youtube now favors sharing
the most
comments and sharing they don't really
care about the likes because for some
reason they don't want it to contrast
with a dislike so there are a couple of
reasons here yes a company screwed up i
want to be clear about that but we have
major supply chain issues as well and
this is not the fault of one company
with contamination so manufacturers are
having difficulty you know sort of
procuring raw ingredients so like cow's
milk which is the base for many formulas
it's increasingly hard to come by you
guys know that packaging labor shortages
also they've been contributing to this
problem now yes there was a place abbot
laboratories right they're one of the
places that uh produces a lot of formula
yeah uh and they had uh uh well okay
there's been an argument as to whether
there was contamination or not i don't
want to get into that it's parents sued
them they claim that they it was
contaminated with a i believe a bacteria
when they searched the facility they
only found it in a place where nothing
uh that actually would be shipped out
would have had contact with it
regardless
abbott voluntarily recalled a bunch of
its product including a lot of similac
formulas that's a very popular formula
for mothers out there you guys can can
testify another acid reflux one too yeah
right yeah yeah and uh they received
complaints it was what was the bacteria
chronobacter sakazaki yeah nice it's you
nailed it
it's what like really similar to
salmonella it's just so it's like the
wuhan flu of salmonella i would have
called that chrono back jet ski yeah
good for you
i would have caught a chrono-backed or
sea-doo would have gone name-brand oh
wow
so five so let me give you the story
that the media wants to give you and
then there's a little bit more to it
five uh infants children babies
hospitalized after consuming the formula
from sturgis uh
michigan
two died horrible yeah that's why you
see pictures like this when you go to
the stores you have these warnings now
here's the thing it is a problem because
and this is what you see with big banks
you see it with airline companies you
see with health insurance companies the
baby formula industry is dominated by a
handful of companies you see it with big
tech as well really just four companies
there's uh wreck-it beckenser there's
nestle and there's uh perigo or porrigo
i don't necessarily know how it's
pronounced i don't really care i don't
like italians now
hey
that's why i don't like them see right
there that always got to make their
voice heard on something so anytime you
look at an industry go okay look i
understand okay this company screwed up
but why are there only a handful how do
you develop this monopoly duopoly
tripopoly or a quadopoly whatever it is
at this point
you don't see this in many industries
you don't see it with restaurants you
don't see it with uh even like for
example manufacturing equipment you see
it
in a few selected you see it with big
banks you see it with airlines you see
it with health insurance companies you
see it with big tech you see it here
these are industries the one commonality
that are incredibly
heavily regulated now to be clear i know
it sounds good oh heavy regulation if
you believed that it actually worked
keep in mind remember i told you that
abbott voluntarily recalled it
the fda didn't catch it
the company recalled it after the harm
was done and then the fda steps in and
says i recognize this fault everybody
look how good i am and they're useless
and then they just make it more
difficult and more expensive for other
companies to make it into the
marketplace and compete
so
uh 2021 parents were wanting to make
individual choices right on baby formula
it was blocked by the fda
and uh they cited insufficient amounts
of iron for issuing there was this
recall that was issued for insufficient
amounts of iron there was a brand uh hip
i don't know what this means holly and
kendamil they were part of a 76 000 unit
recall okay
the fda said there were insufficient
amounts of iron yeah well so the fda is
kind of doing the job that they're
supposed to be doing in that case what
in other cases what if your family has a
history of like uh hemochromatosis yeah
in other words individual choice you
need to account for individual choices
it affects one in 300 white people
in which the body can build up too much
iron in the skin heart liver pancreas by
the way this is something that's very
well known it's the reason that
people's body pro processes iron
differently i just gave blood yesterday
because i have to keep an eye on it i've
always tended to have higher iron levels
men's multivitamins women's the only
real difference is no iron because women
can excrete iron men can't we know what
excess iron does to the body and it's a
pretty common problem parents should
have the right to pick formula that is
lower in iron the fda said no no
absolutely not so they don't allow that
choice
okay
um
let's look at this too the tariffs
there's 17 and a half percent for infant
formula
coming in
jeez jeez now biden wants to eat he's
tariffs on china right their goods to
reduce inflation now uh what about
easing tariffs on these other
formulas and by the way a lot of baby
formulas coming over from europe i don't
know if we have this necessarily in the
show but there was a bunch of formula
that was coming in from europe germany
and it didn't meet labeling laws
specific fda labeling laws which by the
way you want to know how useless the fda
labeling laws are guess what you can
have food that can be within 10 percent
which is a problem for the uh uh
for the diabetic community whether it's
fda usda they they have these very in
other words you would accept it if you
go well it's because our standards are
far more stringent no it's not more
stringent than germany where this
formula is allowed
it's just because of a technicality so
in europe they can get access to this
but here in the united states you can't
so we have tariffs we want to ease it on
china right now when we need the formula
we don't allow americans to make choices
and we put tariffs on the formula that
would come in from europe where is
perfectly acceptable and probably better
than what we're getting from abbott
laboratories the point is when you
eliminate choice and you create all this
red tape it makes the barrier to entry
impossible and so there is less
competition something else
the fda didn't enforce the regulations
that were already on the books they
inspected abbott
in september 2021
with the following findings unsanitary
conditions in the building itself
failure to wash hands
and failure to test for microbes in the
final product they also had an outbreak
in 2020.
what do they get a warning
who are you hans bricks
wow
so the point is this the fda doesn't
look look
i don't think it's a legitimate role for
the government to say that you can't
take something let's say an experimental
drug if you're willing to accept the
risk right i do think it's a legitimate
role of the government to make sure that
you know the risk of something you are
consuming from a company or making sure
that the company isn't lying to you
about what is in there for example if
they say hey we don't put lead paint
chips in our baby formula they have it
in giant bright
loud letters with singing whistles okay
just have to make sure that you don't
actually have lead paint chips in your
formula that's the fda's job and they
don't do it right and they actually had
a whistleblower for that plant that you
mentioned earlier the sturgis michigan
plant they had a whistleblower i believe
in october that came forward they didn't
investigate or contact the whistleblower
until december and i don't think they
actually went and looked at the plan
until a couple of months after that yeah
and that's the issue that we had now
their response just like with gas prices
right now just like with any of the
other inflation is corporations bad
that's the left's response every single
time no government bureaucracy bad
historically communist governments have
always had shortages when they step in
too much this is something very similar
to that like you said in wine you have
to have the alcohol percentage on the
label it's tiny and insignificant it
doesn't matter but if you don't have it
you can't sell your product that's the
kind of technicality we're talking about
what's also absurd though is that with
wine and beer you don't have to list the
ingredients but you do have other food
right yeah and that's for babies how
much arsenic is in wine i'm not even
kidding really take a look at it well i
guess it's a good thing that i'm just a
bottle of whiskey a day man and old lace
yep well it's a lot of cecilia but just
enough to take your wine and your
healthy heart i will take my
whiskey and chesterfield you're about to
say something
though everything you guys are saying
about the fda it makes complete sense
there's it's everything is over
that's for regular formula
that's just after finnegan had a little
doesn't it seem like it's over or under
though like it just feels like it's like
ace rothstein and casino where yeah if
you have enough money they just keep
putting the application at the bottom of
the pile that's what i'm yeah that's
kind of the point that i was getting to
is yes the fda there's and the
government has way too many regulations
the barriers to entry
prevent smaller firms from breaking
through yeah but i also feel like as
conservative sometimes we automatically
have the kind of reactionary response
and say oh well government bad
corporation is good right that shouldn't
be in this case i think they're both
incompetent as i'll get out because
how did these five companies get this
market share
by running the better business in
everybody no exactly they get protection
and here's the thing too though the
market ended up correcting itself
unfortunately after damage was done
right now if you have more competition
there's less damage that is done think
of it right think of it as a mouth guard
the way a mouth guard works is it
dissipates shock right that's why it
makes it really hard to knock your teeth
out people like a little rubber is not
gonna stop that's not enough of a shield
it's that it dissipates the
reverberation of the shock and so you're
less likely to lose one tooth more
competition it just it dissipates the
shock it means that fewer people are
affected it means that the risk is
mitigated the problem is when the
government gets involved and you have
this over regulation what ends up
happening is it ends up creating these
leviathans these super companies and
then that shock is so much more
impactful yeah so right now there's an
opportunity if you're an upstart formula
producer right now and you want to
increase production and or maybe jump
into the game and you weren't you were
doing something similar but not formula
you can't the regulations right now make
it and the price of everything else yeah
and you don't but and that's the market
you're correcting these companies have
people behind the scenes lobbying for
those regulars
because they're the ones that can afford
to live by the way it's like the big
banks or amazon of course amazon is okay
with increasing payroll tax because they
can afford it and it's just going to
push their competitors out exactly right
exactly if you look at organizations
like blackrock and vanguard right these
organizations they they all you know
what perfect example big tech
when people say oh big corporations look
at the most powerful corporations that
have ever existed why do you think
youtube right alphabet google youtube uh
this is all under alphabet facebook
twitter microsoft apple why do you think
they entirely support democrats for you
you you believe that susan wojcicki that
jeff bezos that tim cook that mark
zuckerberg
are looking out for you
do you actually believe that all of them
somehow woke up and said you know this
is what's best for the the american
people and not what's best for my
company or shareholders no this is
what's happening with the formula right
now and here's the thing
it happened there was a contamination
and now the government has stepped in
and said we will do our work and all
they're doing is freezing
anything that can be done at this point
yeah well stores aren't going to get a
lot more product abbot said until july
they're ramping up production as fast as
they can but that's two months you know
what the government solution also is
stephen like oh what did we do during
world war ii let's let's put it under
the defense production act so that the
government can now control it or let's
add it to the strategic stockpile like
the masks and stuff we didn't have right
in this and it's like oh government's
stepping in and doing more of a bad job
do you understand how this was just like
look this is just like the fbi the fbi
is okay you're busy prosecuting people
who are wearing
you're not going after the pedophiles
and actual domestic terrorists you're
going after people who are on the
capitol law with funny hats this is the
broadboard meetings right we just had
that come out in the last couple of days
they did go after people on the school
board or beer drinking clubs where they
didn't even want to kidnap the governor
fbi that was you so you don't have time
to go after the people who actually
matter this is what happens with the fda
anyone out there who has a job
you know what let's let's use an analogy
here with mothers which is at least 30
percent of the country yes at least
30 countries well it depends it depends
on which metrics you're using it's let's
call it a solid 15. it's fair fair so if
you're a mother
and let's say you have a baby who has uh
acid reflux yeah you talk about that
takes some of your energy right you have
to focus on the acid reflux yeah the
focus on that problem you have to deal
with it like prilosec is something that
a lot of people use and is recommended
mayo uh when i've worked with them they
probably sacrifice detroit children's
hospital we're talking about that
same uh no by the way i'm not sponsored
by prilosec just to be clear okay i'm
not stephen colbert's sponsored by a big
pharma company but what i'm saying is if
you're a mom right you have a baby with
some kind of an ailment some kind of a
disorder some kind of special need guess
what you know that your time is limited
we often don't understand that time is a
currency and you can't spend that time
addressing other problems if the fda is
busy grandstanding and right now virtue
signaling they can't do their actual job
and their actual job should be just
ensuring that what they claim is on the
label is on the label not making up new
labels
not shutting down companies not not
forcing people to take export of the cdc
take experimental medicine hey the cdc
should actually be you know compiling
statistics more accurately instead
they're lobbying the government to make
sure that you have to take a vaccine you
only have so much time it's limited and
so we see as the fda grows in scope and
grows in power they're not doing the job
that they were basically designed to do
which is ensure that consumers can make
decisions with accurate information so i
am pretty
libertarian i believe in limited
government
but i also don't believe that
corporations should simply be able to go
out and lie right the fda has no
interest in enforcing the truth they
have the opportunity they just glance
past it why because they're more
interested in making it seem like
they're working than actually doing
their job and everyone who works at job
knows it's way easier to make it seem
like you're doing a job than actually
doing your job yeah what does the biden
administration really think like do you
really care about the poor do you really
care about people like that if this is
the issue if this is what's going on
right and lane like what you're talking
about with
like let's say somebody does get the
ingredients they need by some miracle or
whatever and they're allowed to have
production make baby formula how long
would it actually take like this
couldn't actually fix a problem
overnight or even close to it like how
like it would be what
years months
it's for another company it would be
years and right now we're looking at
months for the shortage yeah
yeah but here's the thing so it ran at
january to april i think the stat was uh
somewhere but three to eight percent
right out of stock right so if you're a
company if you're an enterprising
company you're out there going okay
that's normal and then you start to see
oh it's up to 11 now oh it's up to 30
guys there's a there's a market
opportunity
something is coming we can jump into
this game right if you're in that kind
of world already making food products
you might be able to transfer over and
go after it but you can't if there's too
much government red tape if it's going
to take you a year to get into the
approval process and get your product to
the market right you can't do it and
people are and this is what i want to be
really clear because it's easy to go
corporations evil government good when
you say red tape when we say red tape we
don't mean making sure that the
companies are providing a safe product
for you they don't enforce that
the product already got out what we mean
is red tape with your paper sitting on a
stack red tape well this label doesn't
have the right font size or you know
what you know sorry you can't use comic
sans whatever the hell it is right i
agree with it has to be in helvetica
what about helvetica bold no
never but we know that we can't just
rush something it's dangerous no no no
no no
no what no
no you almost had me
and then you did have me yes
so tom cotton uh actually called out the
fda in the bind administration on
twitter he said the fda needs to step up
immediately be transparent explain how
it will get production restarted and
give parents a timeline
the biden administration needs to take
this seriously that's a okay that's a
fair statement that's a fair request i
think we have a path to how we can do
that here however when asked uh what the
fda fd the fda was i almost said f-a-a
and i said fda i also hate the faa
when they were asked what the just
three-letter organizations they're all
just the pits
when they were asked what the fda was
doing to fix the problem jen sucky gave
this incredibly coherent response
what the fda is doing which while
they're independent they are part of the
administration is taking another number
of steps to address that includes
working with major infant formula
manufacturers to ensure they're
increasing production getting a weird
alzheimer's of course making sure
they're stuck on the shelves right
chelsea
and working with the industry right now
to optimize their supply lines product
sizes to increase capacity and
prioritizing product lines that are of
greatest need could you you couldn't
hear that could you no but i put that in
there so okay yeah yeah yeah i'll always
just optimizing supply lines
what yeah
it's like every word from a business
school exactly
it's synergy can you imagine if she just
comes in as an efficiency expert to your
company she's like okay let me see all
right let me see the bottle
yeah well seems here what you need to do
is
optimize i mean that's mckenzie like
yeah it is my work here
no i love what she said basically the
market does this she's like we're
working with them to make sure that they
understand that there's a demand for a
product that they make and that if they
make more of it they'll sell more of it
and get more money i'm like
did you really need to call them for
that yes every other company right now
is like oh baby market share let's go
you don't have to call for that no you
don't have to get out of the way we
called them and we told them that people
need we called the baby formula company
and told them that there are people who
want to purchase baby formula and uh
we'll let you know what they come back
with yeah we're going to use a bunch of
words you don't understand the whole
thing and i guess my last point on this
is it's just kind of a sick incestuous
relationship between like left-wing
politics and these big business people
the cronies yes it's
okay
the government makes regulations
left-wing politicians make regulations
that only mega companies can afford to
implement right right they push the
market to push everyone else out of the
market and then they continue to fund
the re-election campaigns yes or the
same people that are going to make more
regulations to make them more powerful
and it just because you and i were
talking about this unfortunately you
were talking about you know uh um like
plastics you know getting pla they were
getting plastics from i think i don't
know how it came out we were talking
about right uh was it the bottles for
the formula yeah the plastic getting it
from china you're saying why don't they
get that you know be able to get that
from wisconsin and i agree look i agree
that it would be fantastic if we could
get everything in the united states it's
not possible sometimes right for example
the mugs that we sell we get the mugs
from china they're hand painted and
etched in the united states do you know
why
no one could if please send what's what
tips at lotterycrowder.com sure tips if
there's an american company that can
make this mug yeah we're looking to the
scale that we need
let us know not a shitty mug with a
screen print but
but the truth is there aren't america
there weren't there haven't been any
american companies who are willing to
make it or who can scale to what we need
same thing often with plastics you know
wisconsin well it's a big union state
the st steel steel and the furniture
industry long before kova they had to go
to eastern bloc country i don't know if
it's lithuania or latvia i could
something with an l in there maybe it's
belarus i have no idea
well that was that was by the way
pittsburgh the steel shut down long
before we stopped needing steel oh yeah
it was too expensive and the quality was
lower because you have unions who elect
democrats and then the democrats say
we'll give you kickbacks and eventually
it ends up killing the industry because
no one wants to go to them for raw
materials so it'll be great kind of like
you're saying it's a reactionary uh sort
of response for uh conservatives to say
oh corporations good government bad
which of course none of us agree with
it's also
a little bit of a reactionary response
where you have people you should buy
american right you have people like
you're driving a jet you're driving a
jack car you should buy american well
see the thing that you feel to
understand sir is i've driven enough
american cars
no i completely agree with that i guess
don't the only thing that i would add on
to that is mo a lot of these companies
that could produce these things in
america outside of like the union
regulations yeah do it for cost
effectiveness so you don't have a
minimum wage in china you can have
weaker muslims make whatever you want
for free because yeah you know they're
not people according to the chinese
government so they outsource stuff there
and instead of
preparing for a strong economy that can
be
that can respond well to black swan
events like kovid right they
went for we need to make every single
penny we can by cutting costs everywhere
we can offshore jobs offshore production
and unfortunately that's also
exacerbated by the government taxes and
by making you know profit margins are
very very slim for a lot of companies
don't understand that and so it
encourages and then of course when you
say we're going to reduce tariffs from
china on goods from china so now okay
it's now
it's even more cost effective and by the
way we're going to levy more taxes on
you it's like oh my gosh my profit
margins just shrank and they just gave
me an incentive to get things from china
yeah and that's the problem that we have
and that is where the america first
donald trump people say it was racist
you look at what happened with ford you
look at it happen with companies where
it actually became more cost effective
for a good example
within the united states elon musk tesla
yeah it's the electric car it should
live in california he went to texas we
could do that on an international level
unfortunately we're not well there's
just too many people that want to look
at corporations and wag their finger but
they're getting the campaign funds from
them and say all we have to do is tax
these windfall profits that's what
robert reich that [ __ ] keeps saying and
i'm just like you've got to be kidding
me that's not what's driving our problem
the problem is this administration
doesn't have a clue on how to handle
inflation and reopening an economy yeah
it was obvious
economy yeah the economy exactly they're
great at making inflation work for this
but the economy it was obvious that it
was coming back anyone who was trying to
get into politics at that time and be a
leader at any level should have known
this thing's about to open wide and we
need to be ready for it and yet you put
the mayor of a small town in indiana in
in the position as secretary of
transportation and it's like oh good
yeah he's going to know a whole lot
about how to handle this we're crying
all right that guy doesn't that guy
doesn't even drive because you can't you
keep ubers you can't drive home on ghb
from adonis club no
poke
he was the mayor of south bend and he
worked for mckenzie's
qualified yes
oh it took three months left chest feet
as well yeah south bend there's lots to
do there like drink and go to a college
that's not so good well that college
technically is not in south bend it is i
know
look let me just say no it's michiana
let me distill this for you okay really
quickly because people trying to make
this very and i agree with a lot of the
points that you're making and i think
there's a big difference between crony
capitalism and corporatism who by the
way this is one of the biggest most
powerful companies in the world and also
the big banks uh favor democrats
overwhelmingly it's not even close big
tech big banks look at the big media
when you talk about corporate media man
why do you think they're overwhelmingly
democrats it's not even close uh so
they're not looking out for you that
being said
yes abbott screwed up had this
contamination the level
the degree of which we don't necessarily
know right the fda didn't do their job
that's the only reason that the
contamination got out and affected
people however look
occam's razor here
do you think that all of the the entire
shortage of baby formula that affects
all of you right now and children
uh which is pr well probably why
republicans conservatives are more
concerned with it you know yeah because
they want them to live well that's
true do you think that it's affected uh
because of one company
abbott laboratories uh had a
contamination you know to a small degree
um or
do you think that there's a shortage
with formula for perhaps the same reason
that there's been a shortage and
inflation of everything
now this is more severe but remember
when there were empty shelves not long
ago the media said no it's not happening
it's not true everybody who's been doing
grocery shopping and this is why i say
talk with moms guess what yeah if the
moms are doing the grocery shopping in
the house they've seen the shelves
they've gone to where we go kroger tom
thumb target walmart cvs i've made those
runs we've seen them for ourselves the
media can only for so long say don't
believe your line eyes and lioness they
just never saw the formula shelves
completely barren so is it just because
of one company and ooh corporation bad
and they should be the target of our ire
or is it just a more severe version of
what we've been seeing for months this
the commonality across the board
is
what is this administration is the
government intervention is the policies
that we have been enacting and by the
way it's important to look at the
contrast between then and now two years
ago versus what you're seeing the
shelves are empty for a long time
depending on what it was beef milk eggs
take your pick in any given week there
was something that you couldn't find now
it's formula
look for the constant look for the
pattern doesn't mean that corporations
are blameless of course not i'm not the
party of big business i'm not the party
of small business i'm the party of good
business i don't care how big you are so
long as you're not taking my tax dollars
for subsidization and so long as you're
not lying to me now we know that
everything might seem hopeless with all
these endless government regulations
these competent companies
making baby formula they also shouldn't
have mr magu on the factory i don't know
why they did that i mean everything yeah
it was silly but our team did uncover
one last reliable source and this is
actually research that came from
gingersnap uh
he uncovered this stream he did uncover
this we have an exclusive uh this is our
new segment street beats and we hope
that it helps
mothers in need
[Music]
yeah there's some good formula right
here
good
baby formula right here here comes a
customer right now please step aside
camera crew
so uh you were looking uh for some baby
formula or something yeah man i heard
you got some of that baby formula with
iron oh i got some baby formula with i'm
right here for you right now oh my
baby's so hungry man can i buy something
oh your baby is so hungry right now what
you got five thousand dollars for your
baby the hunger
five thousand dollars man come on i'll
give you like 200 bucks please oh i
don't got time for that kind of sad
story i need five thousand dollars for
this pure baby formula do you take
jobs jobs or maybe jobs i'll do a job a
job but yeah no job sorry not into that
okay get in all right
all right uh
would you mind holding my baby while
yeah it's probably safer yeah i guess
just
make sure she's not looking at me okay
okay
i think the things you do for family you
know
i'm actually gonna pull over okay and
feed her real quick oh you're real
hungry yeah that's a really good idea
let me just taste it make sure it's pure
there you go
son of a [ __ ] this is cocaine
[Music]
couple of notes the hat isn't enough of
a disguise but your child will be
productive as hell yes that's true uh up
all night screaming yes well and
cleaning yeah cleaning cleaning
also uh buying more baby formula i
needed a dad hat yes
so that's what i mean
so i realized i looked in the mirror i'm
like this is not how a man who's almost
40 used to dress that's when i stopped
wearing hoodies did you know that i
looked in the mirror and i was like i
can't wear these anymore i'm a man yeah
this is and i i put on today a shirt
with a monkey and a space on with
smoking a cigarette well i like it i
like it because monkeys would not
typically be found smoking cigarettes
they would not well if they're about to
well what if they're typing though in
the 50s at a comedy show i particularly
also like it when babies talk like
adults yes that's my favorite those are
the two things i enjoy yeah also babies
do tend to talk like adults when you
give them cocaine yeah you know that
yeah they do yeah it's true it activates
that portion of their brain yep
something about it absolutely does don't
even get me started on crack oh wow you
have to blow it in their face yeah yeah
i mean people people use the term crack
baby like it's a bad thing i know right
i mean it's just an untapped resource we
could have an army of crack babies i
would take an army of crack babies over
the representatives that we have in the
halls of congress right now i once saw a
crack baby
turn over a bus to save its mother no no
that was jesus at the temple oh yeah
there was no crack involved it was just
anger at them selling stuff oh at the
temple oh no wait the crack baby did
that too yeah oh okay okay oh okay both
things can be true yeah so look i have a
we we have a segment here i think we're
gonna i want to get into a little bit
more so we'll we'll do this a little bit
next week because everyone gets mad if
we don't do enough chats on chat
thursday however the cdc uh i think was
may 10th
put out stats on uh crime yeah the
increasing homicide rate and they tried
to say it was systemic racism inequities
caused by kovid
look i'll just give you a spoiler alert
uh no if you add it up racially those
who would be systemically oppressed they
make up 76 of a homicide which is a
staggeringly low rate but all suicides
are by white people so i looked at it
read the pdf i said this doesn't pass
the sniff test wait those who are
oppressed are killing other people who
are oppressed because there's black
unblack prime crime brown and brown
crime but the oppressors the white
people are killing themselves
that racist against them they're racist
against themselves
so white people are committing suicide
but black and brown people to a rate of
75 to 78 percent
are committing the homicides and it's
because they're oppressed but they're
not committing the suicides which by the
way that's a good thing we should look
into if there's some kind of genetic
genetically if there's a protective gene
for african americans against the
suicide well wouldn't they be killing
the oppressors if they were being
oppressed you would think so but that's
far too sensible we'll discuss this more
in a way that we could never discuss on
youtube because race and you know what
we'll also talk about uh
uh uh women with penises too because we
can't talk about it on youtube because
it's immutable so right now i'm going to
hit the leave leave a smash the like
button
share comment it's okay you don't need
to hit that tim they know they know they
don't need an on-screen prompt you know
and uh right now i'm gonna hit the mute
button on youtube
you